bien bonjour à tous avec valérie
brigitte et guillaume on est très
heureux de faire ce point presse de
rentrée
dans cette configuration nouvelle
quelques mots d'abord sur la rentrée
parlementaire
telle qu'elle est organisée par le
gouvernement en place c'est une rentrée
chaotique
françois hollande ajoute de la crise à
la crise françois mitterrand en son
temps avait dénoncé le coup d'état
permanent
françois hollande lui invente un nouveau
concept c'est le flou d'état permanent
et ses ambiguïtés ajoute de la crise à
la crise il ya aujourd'hui une crise
institutionnelle
lorsque le garde des sceaux ministre de
la justice chargé de défendre un projet
de loi constitutionnelle devant le
parlement annonce répète matin midi et
soir qu'elle y est opposée c'est une
crise institutionnelle parce que la
ministre de la justice défi le président
de la république et lui dénie toute
autorité crise institutionnelle crise
politique interne à la majorité
on pourrait même dire crise de nerfs
interne au parti socialiste il ya 47
positions ennemies sur tous les sujets
on ne comprend plus rien crise sociale
lorsque 5,7 millions de demandeurs
d'emploi sont inscrits à pôle emploi
lorsque l'appauvrissement des français
est une réalité hélas avec un pib par
habitant qui pour la première fois en
2015 est inférieure en france de 6 % à
la moyenne des pays développés crise
sociale crise financière puisque notre
pays est désormais hélas dans la mains
de créanciers internationaux puisque
une dette publique qui est en jantes 100
% de la production nationale
crise financière crise démographique
aussi puisque pour la première fois en
2015 on a une chute des naissances de 2
75% crise sécuritaire
il est d'ailleurs complètement
hallucinant que le ministre de
l'intérieur ait cru pouvoir déclaré hier
que les français n'avaient jamais été
aussi protéger ce qui est hallucinant
il n'y a jamais eu autant d'actes de
délinquance criminelle ou
correctionnelle en france qu'en 2015 ont
valeur absolue et lorsque le ministre de
l'intérieur dit bien imprudemment que
les français n'ont jamais était aussi
protégé il faudra qu'ils nous expliquent
notamment comment monsieur abdelaziz
yade condamnés pour terrorisme pouvait
exercer sous une fausse identité à 3
comme prédicateur il faudra qu'ils nous
expliquent aussi si les français sont
mieux protégés que jamais comment ils
sont mieux protégés alors que le
désarmement pénale de madame taubira
produit tous ses effets avec la
suppression des peines planchers et la
multiplication des pseudos peine
alternative à la prison
gris sécuritaire crise européenne nous
en parlerons aussi des initiatives à
venir qui nous préoccupe et nous vous en
dirons quelques mots la france a reculé
sur la scène européenne ne fait plus
entendre sa voix il serait temps qu'elle
qu'elle réaffirme sa voix et puis crise
migratoire
nous en parlerons aussi crise migratoire
très très préoccupante très inquiétante
qui fragilise la communauté nationale
qui fragilise notre pays
de tout cela nous allons vous vous
parlez un peu ce matin et puis surtout
nous allons le développer aussi au
parlement puisque c'est la rentrée
parlementaire
vous verrez que bizarrement d'ailleurs
la rentrée parlementaire cet après midi
à l'assemblée nationale ça commence par
un débat sans doute très intéressant sur
le thème de la gestion des déchets sujet
de préoccupation important techniques
que nous négligeons pas mais enfin qui
est quand même pas au coeur de
l'actualité
ça c'est le début de l'assemblée
nationale mais nous nous poserons bien
sûr demain lors de la séance de
questions d'actualité puis mercredi lors
des travaux de commission beaucoup de
questions l'opposition les républicains
sont à l'initiative et on va notamment
dès cette semaine
déclinée à l'assemblée ce que le bureau
politique la semaine dernière a choisi
dénoncé s'agissant de la révision
constitutionnelle
les républicains ont exprimé des
demandes ces demandes nous allons bien
sûr les exprimer à l'assemblée nationale
nous exigeons du gouvernement qu'ils
nous transmettent dès cette semaine son
avant projet de loi organique
appliquant son projet de révision
constitutionnelle car nous souhaitons
avoir les idées claires et bien
comprendre précisément ce que le
gouvernement propose
et puis nous présenterons aussi le
moment venu
évidemment des amendements pour traduire
dans les textes les positions exprimées
par le bureau politique des républicains
en ce qui concerne en particulier le
retrait de la nationalité
son chant son rythme d'application enfin
bref tous les sujets que vous connaissez
qui ont été présentés la semaine
dernière et sur lesquelles si vous le
souhaitez nous pourrons revenir bien
merci de votre attention je passe la
parole à guillaume
merci cher guillaume bonjour à tous
quelques mots dans le prolongement de ce
qu'évoquait guillaume de ce que porte et
nicolas sarkozy lors de l'accueil des
nouveaux adhérents samedi dernier l'un
des maîtres mots de cette première
conférence de presse c'est la frontière
le mot de frontières qui est devenu dans
la vie politique française un mot tabou
doit être réhabilité c'est ce qu'a dit
nicolas sarkozy
samedi matin avec force avec courage
avec détermination et
nous souhaitons puisque évoquer cette
crise migratoire c'est inquiétudes très
fortes de nos concitoyens et de nos
compatriotes sur la question de
l'immigration de la maîtrise des
contrôles aux frontières nous
demandons-nous au nom des républicains
ce matin le rétablissement des contrôles
permanents aux frontières c'est plus
loin que l'état d'urgence puisque ya pas
de lien juridique entre les deux nous
avons qu'aujourd'hui il ya entente de
contrôle qui existe monsieur cazeneuve
l'a évoquée nous avons probablement
quelle occasion de l'euro 2016 ces
contrôles seront demandés nous savons
dans le cadre de schengen que pour des
mariages princiers en espagne ou à
monaco ces contrôles permanents furent
rétablies
eh bien nous nous demandons aujourd'hui
au nom de la sécurité des français et
des européens
le rétablissement des contrôles
permanents aux frontières car la
frontière est un atout considérable dans
le monde qui vient dans le monde
compliqué qui est le nôtre nous devons
avoir le courage de le dire et de porter
cette conviction
toujours dans le cadre de l'idée de
frontière nous avons nous une inquiétude
ce matin et nous nous interrogeons à
travers vous le gouvernement françois
hollande manuel valls
monsieur macron sur la question des
frontières commerciales en 2001 la chine
a obtenu de l'union européenne le statut
de d'intégration de au sein de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce la
chine a intégré en 2001 l'om s'est il
fut prévu à l'époque que quinze années
après nous y sommes en 2016 de manière
automatique la chine se voit accorder le
statut d'économie de marché c'est à dire
que les droits de douane soient
supprimés entre la chine et l'union
européenne
la commission européenne a commandité un
rapport que nous avons
lu avec attention vous donne un chiffre
qui symbolisent les inquiétudes très
lourde que vont connaître nos
compatriotes
ce changement de statut de la chine
vis-à-vis de l'union européenne pourrait
entraîner la perte de 183 1000 à 367
1000 emplois dans notre pays 180 3000 à
367 1000 emplois perdus dans notre pays
et c'est peut-être cette entre 1,7
million et 3 5 millions au niveau de
l'union européenne
nous demandons donc deux choses
premièrement au gouvernement et à
françois hollande de préciser sa
position sur cette question puisque la
commission de bruxelles a prévu de
donner un premier avis mercredi prochain
l'inquiétude des européens dans une
période on l'a vu très lourde dans le
domaine économique et social
l'inquiétude de nos compatriotes sur la
question de l'emploi du travail et
première prioritaire nous devons avoir
des réponses fortes sur la question
quelle est la position du gouvernement
sur l'éventuel changement de statut de
la chine qui obtiendrait donc ce statut
d'économie de marché et puis deuxième
chose quelle est notre position nous les
républicains nous sommes favorables 1 à
la protection commerciale européenne
nous considérons que les frontières
commerciales au niveau européen
c'est fondamental l'union européenne
n'est pas un courant d'air entre deux
océans
l'union européenne doit pour se
réconcilier avec les peuples européens
savoir se protéger et protéger nos
intérêts économiques et commerciaux
d'ailleurs la chine elle-même l'amérique
les etats unis savent se protéger à
travers des droits de douane qui protège
les intérêts économiques de ces nations
ou de ces unions commerciales et bien
l'union commerciale européenne doit
savoir se protéger et donc la ligne de
conduite qui est la nôtre qui est celle
de la famille des républicains
c'est une protection européenne
commercial souple pragmatique
intelligente mais le terme de protection
comme le terme de frontières sont des
mots auxquels nous
profondément attaché je vois sa parole à
valérie merci merci guillaume
bonjour à toutes et à tous dans la
description des crises que nous a faite
guillaume larrivé il y en a une qui nous
interroge tout particulièrement
puisqu'il touche à nos concitoyens c'est
la crise sociale la crise du chômage
et là nous voyons une crise
institutionnelle une crise
gouvernementale puisque madame l
connerie en fait à a signifié et bien la
fin de la promesse du président de la
république et de la réplique françois
hollande promesses décliné en 2012 en
2013 en 2014 de l'inversion de la courbe
du chômage
promettre sur laquelle je le rappelle
qu'il a bâti sa prochaine éventuelle
candidature à l'élection présidentielle
or madame l comrie nous dit nous n'y
arriverons pas pour l'année à venir
c'est dramatique parce que ça veut dire
que le gouvernement de la république
française nous dit nous ne pouvons pas
inverser la courbe du chômage après
avoir dit le contraire bien sûr mais
surtout nous nous donnons pas les moyens
de le faire et nous renvoyons l'ensemble
des français au chômage de masse donc à
la désespérance et à ses difficultés
majeures que vit notre pays et le tour
de passe passe qui consiste à dire nous
allons former 500 mille demandeurs
d'emploi est un tour de passe passe qui
a fait long feu puisque l'ensemble des
syndicats qu'ils soient d'ailleurs
patronaux et de salariés ont
immédiatement pointé cette proposition
qui de toute façon ne sera pas
réalisable dans le temps et qui en plus
ne fera que renvoyer le co2 la formation
sur l'ensemble des régions de france qui
ont la compétence en la matière ne nous
leurrons pas les vingt-et-une régions
socialistes
ils sont pas arrivés pendant le mandat
qui vient de s'écouler
il ne faudrait pas voir que désormais
qu'il ya un certain nombre de régions
qui sont majoritaires qui soit à droite
on essaierait de leur faire porter cette
responsabilité
donc en la matière
les présidents de région ne seront pas
dupes même si eux est en tout cas ceux
qui appartiennent à notre majorité ne
vont pas se démobiliser mais au
contraire vont prendre à bras le corps
eu cette volonté nous trouverons
désespérant de la part de ce
gouvernement
cet abandon est grosso modo cette
incapacité affichée et revendiquée a agi
sur un autre champ et avec gravité nous
souhaitons indiqué que les événements
passés lors des fêtes de fin d'année à
cologne et hambourg nous inquiète
inquiète les français
si vous regardez pas seulement les
réseaux sociaux mais si vous échangez
avec l'ensemble de nos compatriotes
c'est un des premiers sujets qui revient
ce sujet est empreint de gravité
puisqu'on nous dit qu'il y aurait
aujourd'hui plus de 600 plainte qui
aurait été déposée par des femmes dont
40% de ces plaintes auraient pour
origine une agression à caractère sexuel
promettent les shows temps les choses en
perspective
il faut bien voir que six ans c'est le
nombre d'agressions sexuelles pour viol
qui ont été recensés sur la seule ville
de paris
toute l'année précédente donc on voit
qu'on est sur des volumes d'agression
qui sont extrêmement importants
le ministre allemand en charge a indiqué
ce week end qu'il s'agirait de
phénomènes qui aurait été préparée et
qui aurait été volontaires ne seraient
pas l'effet de regroupement dû au hasard
ceci nous inquiète nous souhaitons
témoigner évidemment vis-à-vis de toutes
les femmes victimes
notre totale solidarité mais nous
souhaitons aussi parce que l'allemagne
c'est l'europe et l'europe c'est notre
territoire commun nous souhaitons dire
que la lumière doit être faite
nous devons savoir ce qui s'est
réellement passé et tout comme
l'ensemble de nos concitoyens doit être
protégé nous accompagnons toutes les
démarches qui permettront de savoir ce
qui s'est passé
je passe la parole à bree merci pour ma
part je souhaite revenir sur un
événement qui s'est déroulé hier en
seine et marne à fontainebleau avec l'
incendie
deux incendies dans deux églises deux
incendies dont à l'heure actuelle nous
ne connaissons pas évidemment qui en est
à l'origine
accent dix ans tout un incendie en tout
cas criminels incendies qui ont
apparemment laissé de marbre le
gouvernement
comment ne pas s'étonner alors qu'un
patrimoine historique inestimable
hier à brûler il n'y eu aucune réaction
aucune venue d'un membre du gouvernement
y aurait-il donc deux poids deux mesures
pas de mots de madame pellerin ministre
de la culture
pas de déplacement du ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur 15,9 pourtant si
prompt à se déplacer et je veux donc ici
au nom des républicains apporter notre
soutien à toute la communauté qui est
entoure cette église au maire de
fontainebleau que j'ai eu encore au
téléphone ce matin et qui se sent un peu
seul je dois vous le dire au niveau des
instances gouvernementales deuxième un
sujet sur lequel je souhaite revenir
c'est sur la vie de notre mouvement nous
avons connu un temps fort samedi avec le
rendez vous traditionnel de notre
président pour présenter ses voeux aux
nouveaux adhérents
ils étaient plusieurs centaines nous y
étions et nous étions heureux de
retrouver évidemment notre président
avec des chiffres particulièrement
impressionnant en ce début d'année
puisque nous sommes à plus de 230 8000
adhérents avec vous le savez plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de nouveaux
adhérents et ce pour nous le signe d'un
dynamisme
de ce parti nous avons une vie militante
qui est particulièrement vous le savez
riches dans notre différents territoires
et qui va pouvoir s'exprimer dans une
démocratie interne telles que cela avait
été prévu et annoncé par le président
sarkozy 2015 année de la reconstruction
du mouvement et puis deux nouvelles
instances
après les votes de nos statuts et vous
le savez la démocratisation qui permet à
chaque adhérent de voter de se prononcer
sur nos différentes conventions encore
récemment sur la convention sécurité
vous aviez jusqu'à plus de 60000
personnes qui ont donné leur avis et
bien cette démocratisation qui a
commencé au moment de la craie de
l'élaboration de notre projet va se
continuer maintenant dans les instances
dans les instances nationales et dans
les instances locales dans les instances
locales puisque nous avons un grand
rendez-vous d'élections internes les 30
et 31 janvier pour renouveler nos
délégués de circonscription qui est
vraiment l'entité même de la proximité
de nos élus nous allons avoir également
l'élection pour la première fois tel que
l'avait souhaité nicolas sarkozy des
présidents de fédérations au suffrage
universel et ça n'est pas rien car c'est
vraiment là aussi porté au plus près le
désir de nos adhérents de personnalités
qui vont les représenter et qui vont
faire vivre la vie de notre mouvement
nous aurons également si c'est
nécessaire le premier week-end de
février le deuxième tour de ces
élections
et puis un autre rendez vous aussi
important et vous le savez déjà ce sont
les 13 et 14 février puisque nous aurons
à ce moment là les élections du conseil
national lors de notre grande réunion
justement du conseil national 13 et 14
février
nous avons un autre point aussi
d'actualité puisque la vie du mouvement
vous l'avez vu et dans l'ain dans la
démocratisation dans le cadre
d'élections peut-être plus interne mais
dont je souhaite en tant qu'élu de paris
quand même faire référence ce pour la
métropole du grand paris dit la mgp où
nous aurons aussi une élection interne
telles que a été souhaitée pour être
fort dans le débat vous le savez qu'il
va s'annoncer maintenant du grand paris
cette nouvelle instance qui par ailleurs
peut-être sûrement amendable ou
critiquable tels que ça a déjà été dit
mais nous allons avoir avec une aux deux
candidats déclarés et patrick ollier et
gilles carez une primaire qui se
déroulera demain à 17 heures pour
présenter donc notre candidat à la
mission à la métropole du grand paris
nous avons sur 209 candidats enfin sur
209 pardon élus qui seront de ces grands
élus à peu près plus de presque 100 de
chez nous qu'ils pourront prétendre à à
ce vote qui aura lieu donc demain à 17
heures ici dans notre mouvement je vais
maintenant vous passez la parole les uns
et les autres si vous avez des questions
complémentaires
et puis nous vous parlerons évidemment
aussi de la deuxième phase de 2016 si
vous le souhaitez dans le détail de la
vie